bonjour à tous et bienvenue hamon
peut-être tox un petit
mais nos actes alors je vais justement
prendre un instant vous expliquer ce que
signifie un acte sur mon moi l'acte
vient du latin qui signifie actions ou
fait ce qui implicitement indique
quelque chose qui est déjà été accompli
quelque chose qui a été déjà accompli ça
s'inscrit ensuite dans le passé chaque
axe s'inscrivent donc dans le temps vous
faites quelque chose dans le présent dès
maintenant et immédiatement et de
manière immuable immuable qu'on peut
changer s'inscrit ensuite dans le passé
vous pouvez plus le changer de même
qu'il ya une notion d'inéluctabilité il
est huit à militer signifie inévitable
qu'est ce qui est inévitable dans vos
actes ce qui est inévitable c'est que
quelque chose qui a été fait dans le
passé revient à un moment donné dans le
présent alors bien évidemment les
pyramides de khéops que vous pouvez voir
la non pas milan elles datent de moins
de mille cinq cent soixante ans avant
jésus-christ bien qu'elles ont été
construites il ya plus de 4000 ans
aujourd'hui on les retrouve encore
aujourd'hui c'est un exemple parmi tant
d'autres
ce qui veut dire que vous avez bien
d'autres exemples ou qu'on retrouve
aujourd'hui dans le présent notion il
d'immuabilité et notion dîner
d'inéluctabilité qu'est-ce qu'on peut
faire retenir son passé alors son passé
c'est déjà bien parce qu'on a fait déjà
un ensemble d'erreurs dans notre vie
qu'on s'efforce du mieux qu'on peut
à ne pas les reproduire mais notre
propre passé ce n'est pas suffisant
inspirons-nous également du passé de
notre entourage famille amis collègues
de boulot collègues de formation parce
que chacun a déjà fait ses erreurs si on
entend un inspirait ça permettrait de
prendre des raccourcis la vie mais ce
n'est pas assez exhaustif prenons
également le passé de l'histoire de
l'humanité
il a 50 cent ans milan 2011 milan afin
de ne pas reproduire ce qui a déjà été
déjà fait
l'erreur est humaine je pense que je la
prends à personne l'erreur est humaine
c'est normal d'en faire je dis pas qu'il
faut les faire intentionnellement mais
je dis juste que c'est normal mais la
faute c'est le fait de ne pas corriger
ces erreurs
alors quelles que soient les offres que
vous avez pu faire des choses tout petit
comme des choses beaucoup plus grosse
est beaucoup plus importante à corriger
efforçons-nous au quotidien de corriger
ses propres erreurs déjà là je vous ai
parlé d'erreurs donc des choses
relativement négative des choses qui
peuvent prêter à confusion parfois il ya
aussi au cours des années humaines des
choses qu'on a fait de manière positive
inspire au nom également de choses
positives afin de la même manière de
prendre un raccourci dans la vie et
d'aller plus loin encore j'ai un petit
exemple à vous proposer dans plusieurs
petits exemples précis nicolas machiavel
il ya plus de 500 aujourd'hui
il disait que si on ne corrige est pas
un problème quelconque qui arrive à un
moment t on en cours sur un second
problème et ainsi de suite
ce qui veut dire que si vous ne corrigé
par un premier problème vous en a ajouté
un deuxième dessus et au fur et à mesure
des années vous en arrivez à plus de
1000 et c'est un lourd fardeau à porter
est très difficile à corriger
il avait dit ça il ya déjà cinq cents
ans plus de 500 ans ce qui signifie que
cette notion est encore d'actualité
aujourd'hui
nicolas machiavel à son époque qui était
décrié parenthèse historique a été
décriée c'est pour ça que vous
connaissez le terme de machiavélique en
fait c'étaient ses détracteurs qui
voulait le discréditer mais lui il est
resté droit dans ses baskets
alors je dis pas qu'ils avaient des
baskets à florence il ya 500 ans mais je
dis juste qu'il était droit dans ses
baskets et puis il est mort un peu dans
l'oubliette puis 500 ans plus tard ce
qui veut dire aujourd'hui influence dans
la cathédrale santa croce
il existe son propre ton
ou dessus et est inscrit aucun loges
n'est digne d'un si grand nom cinq cents
ans plus tard alors qu'en fait ils
étaient oubliées encore une notion qui
vous êtes et que vous inspire le fait
que quelque chose qui vient du passé se
retrouvent ensuite dans le présent
un autre exemple en la personne de
joseph fourier alors pour ceux qui sont
un peu scientifique d'entre nous joseph
fourier était un physicien français mais
on ignore aussi son côté politique il
était préfet de l'isere donc pas trop
loin d'ici il ya deux cents ans joseph
fourier était né dans une famille très
pauvre à l'âge de 9 ans il a perdu ses
parents et quelques farias heures par ci
par là
il avait même pas le droit à l'éducation
parce qu'il était pauvre on lui disait
de vue que t'es pas noble qui rentrent
pas ça n'a pas empêché de continuer ses
recherches
ça n'a pas empêché de continuer à faire
ce qu'il devait faire et puis un moment
donné petit à petit on l'a reconnu
petite information joseph fourier avait
une amie qui s'appellait sophie germain
à l'époque
donc il ya 200 ans était pas si loin que
ça il ya deux cents ans des femmes
étaient interdites d'entrer dans
l'académie des sciences
joseph fourier il a tout fait pour
qu'elle puisse rentrer elle est devenue
la première femme à entrer dans la cas
de l'académie des sciences à paris
c'était une mathématicienne et joseph
fourier à son époque
encore une fois était décrié parce
qu'ils étaient physicien et donc les
mathématiciens disait c'est pas très
bien ce que tu fais il utilisait un peu
de maths des physiciens disait c'est pas
très bien ce que tu fais donc en fait il
avait le cul entre deux sièges mais il a
continué à faire ce qu'il devait faire
et puis il a inventé les transformée de
fourier tf1 les a pas appelés
transformée de fourier à son époque un
il les a appelés juste transformé et
deux cents ans plus tard ce qui veut
dire aujourd'hui internet est arrivée
parc anger internet je sais pas
quelqu'un c'est un concept un concept de
réseau internet est arrivé et il a fallu
transmettre des données problème c'est
que les données étaient trop grosses on
n'arrivait pas à les faire transmettre
et le concept de transmettre ou est
arrivé on a pu compresser les données
son image vidéo afin justement de
pouvoir les transmettre et à son époque
il était même pas conscients qu'on
allait utiliser son concept de cent ans
plus tard de manière massive et mondiale
encore une fois une notion qui explique
que quelque chose ou pas
il revient ensuite dans le présent un
moment donné alors que pouvons-nous
faire appartenir le passé il faut vivre
dans le présent
il ya une notion d' immédiate c'est à
dire que si vous voulez faire quelque
chose dans l'action vous ne pouvez pas
le faire dans le passé parce que c'est
déjà de dépasser pouvait pas non plus le
faire dans le futur car ce n'est pas
encore arrivé
vous pouvez le faire maintenant la
question qui se pose c'est que doit on
faire maintenant davantage écouter
l'autre nous aimons donner son point de
vue son avis mais vous savez une chose
c'est que on donne son point de vue
parce qu'on pense parfois à avoir raison
ou avoir une certaine vérité
retenez une chose la vérité n'a pas
besoin d'être défendue un jour elle
éclatera
de toute façon à quoi ça sert de
davantage écouter l'autre ça sert déjà
de mettre un pied lorsque j'appelle la
bienveillance alors la bienveillance
tout le monde conceptualise tout le
monde essaie de voir peu près ce à quoi
ça correspond mais à bienveillance est
une notion complexe d'une part et
d'autre part extrêmement sujet
subjective dans le sens où tant qu'on
n'est pas fou tout le monde pense être
bienveillant d'une certaine manière
malheureusement vous êtes le seul à le
penser c'est à dire que la personne qui
lit qui est au courant que vous êtes
vraiment bienveillant de manière
inéluctable
alors que faire davantage s'attarder sur
les résultats obtenus de la personne
avec qui vous parlez c'est un indicateur
beaucoup plus importants que le simple
fait d'avoir l'intention d'être
bienveillant attardez-vous résultats que
vous provoquez avec vos actions pour
déterminer si oui ou non vous êtes
bienveillant un indicateur également le
concept de récurrence raclant c'est
quelque chose qui se répètent à partir
fin je me donne cet exercice c'est à
partir de trois fois quand j'observe un
résultat chez une personne et que cela
ne change pas ça veut dire que je suis
rentré dans un cycle de récurrence ce
qui veut dire qu'au bout de 4 5 10 mille
fois je provoquerais le même résultat
il est peut-être temps de changer de
disque ça c'est un exercice qu'on peut
s'imposer à soi mais bien évidemment
exercice qui s'impose à soi peu oui
également s'imposer aux autres dans le
sens où
nous sommes la moyenne des cinq
personnes qui nous que nous fréquentons
le plus le concept de récurrence que je
vous ai présenté précédemment s'applique
également aux personnes qui vous
entourent vous avez forcément dans votre
tête
un ensemble d'une scie de cinq personnes
de cinq personnes et parmi ces personnes
des personnes qui vont raisons qui vous
ont déjà lésés dans votre vie blessé
voire même anéanti
si vous repérez cette personne il peut y
en avoir plusieurs si vous repère cette
personne et que elle rentre dans le
concept de récurrence considérer dès
lors que cette personne est
potentiellement malveillante pour vous
ce concept de moyenne est très important
pourquoi car quand vous avez une
personne malveillante autour de vous
d'après le cycle de la récurrence vous
êtes à 20% vous-même malveillants
car une personne sur cinq s'affairaient
+ 20 % et vous pouvez monter ce chiffre
là en fonction du nombre de personnes
alors que devons-nous faire face à
savoir se retirer
savoir se retirer de ce qu'on appelle
des relations toxiques or quand je parle
de relation toxique s'est pas forcément
une personne ça peut être un groupe ça
peut être une formation ça peut être un
métier
il est très important d'être capable de
vous annoncer à une situation qui vous
entre guillemets baisse votre propre
moyenne
pourquoi faire ceci pour envisager votre
futur votre futur
s'il pouvait être construits sans regret
ce serait bien un regret c'est un poison
insidieux insidieux ça veut dire qu'ils
entrent dans votre conscience grandi et
ne fait que c'est pendant donc on peut
regretter pendant 40 ans de sa vie c'est
dommage
au bout de 40 ans on dit j'aurais dû
faire ça j'aurais dû justement retirer
entre guillemets une personne de ma vie
en tout cas à prendre ses distances ne
pas le regretter
c'est très important afin justement de
pouvoir construire son avenir
n'oubliez pas que votre présent c'est le
futur de demain c'est votre futur qui se
construit à base de briques de votre
passé vous faites quelque chose dans le
présent ils se retrouvent de manière
immuable dans le passé il revient dans
le présent de manière inéluctable et
bien construire votre futur qui devient
votre présent en résumé soyez
bienveillant la bienveillance dans le
concept que j'ai présentées précédemment
dans le sens orientez votre esprit non
pas sur votre propre intentions mais sur
le résultat obtenu de votre
interlocuteur ou de vos interlocuteurs
avant de terminer stocks
j'ai un petit exercice à vous proposer
de réaliser une bonne action pour soi ou
pour les autres un petit exercice alors
pour toi c'est quoi
par exemple on vous avant faire
peut-être un livre il ya cinq ans de
cela pour vous dire ça te fera plaisir
et que vous ne l'avez jamais lu que vous
l'avez laissé poireauter sur votre table
qu'il a pris la poussière qui est venu
éditions 2001 à sortait le nettoyer un
petit peu la poussière cas dessus prenez
un surligneur et commencer à lire ce
soir les deux premières pages en
surlignant les premiers mots qui vous
parle des phrases qui vous parle vous
savez si vous répétez cette action jour
après jour au bout de quelques semaines
vous lui direz entièrement le livre je
pense que ça a l'air d'être simple comme
ça
léopold faye vous pouvez le faire qu'est
ce qu'une bonne action pour les autres
cette fois ci alors aussi simple que
cela puisse paraître nous pouvons faire
un petit don à une association qui nous
tient à coeur a obligé que son débit
laissant juste assez
pour faire effectuer une bonne action
mais de manière plus physique vous
pouvez inviter votre collègue de tp pour
avoir passé des nuits blanches à rédiger
un rapport avec plein de fautes
d'orthographe dedans mais c'est pas
grave
invitez le à boire un verre pas
forcément du bien parce que ça coûte
cher mais un mais en tout cas un
supermarché où vous avez pris une [ __ ]
une petite bouteille pour le milieu
offrir afin de remercier du temps
consacré et l'énergie passé mais vous
pouvez également dès demain quand vous
allez avoir cours vous pensez à une
salle de cour dans laquelle vous êtes
conviés et de remercier votre professeur
pour le temps consacré à l'énergie
accordé à veut faire de vous quelqu'un
de meilleur demain ça vous pouvez le
faire dès demain
merci de votre bienveillance
[Applaudissements]